you're successful in terms of career and
traditional sense of successful you're a
good friend you normally come on a lot
but you just tweeted how you kind of
like took off for all of August and you
kind of bailed because you're kind of
having a meltdown in which we all have
had before like a digital overload
meltdown uh and you just bailed right
totally it was it was really uh it was
bad I mean it's interesting to think
about like I think this happened to
everyone over covid like their life just
shifted in a weird way
um and my life just became crappy over
covid which is weird because I had this
amazing year like we took a business
public we raised a big fund we got to
work with all these interesting people
we bought some great businesses I didn't
die of covid like all these great things
happened and yet I was totally miserable
um and when I look at it when I kind of
zoom out my old day I don't know if you
guys you guys know but I live in
Victoria Canada and I didn't even have
an office so I actually like just
working out of cafes I would just go to
the same Cafe every day uh and I'd sit
there with headphones on three or four
of my friends would always work there so
it's kind of like cheers there's always
like interesting people to talk to and
my day was just broken up into a bunch
of chunks so any given day I wouldn't
really be on the computer or in one
place for more than an hour or two and
my day went from that to sitting in a
house on my computer all day on zoom and
doing email and it just kind of made me
miserable and so I I am
you know when I look at like what I love
about business I don't actually love you
know doing business is great doing
strategy coming up with ideas all that
kind of stuff but the cool thing about
business is you get to meet interesting
people like business is just a hack
right so like if you're interested in
health you figure out like a health
business you suddenly can meet all the
most interesting people in that World
um and I'm an extrovert so so anyway it
just I was totally bummed and I started
um you know going on Twitter a lot
because I was craving socializing
um I and I I went from like 20 000
followers to 170 000 followers so
I got totally hooked into that and like
a good day would be like I have a viral
tweet or I go on your podcast or
something something exciting happens a
bad day would be I say something on
Twitter I get dunked on I got
misunderstood or it doesn't do well like
what a ridiculous thing like I'd tweet
and it would only get like 50 likes
instead of 5 000 likes that would like
throw my day off so I got to a point
where I was just like Jesus Christ like
this is totally ridiculous I'm thinking
about Twitter constantly I'm checking
Twitter constantly and on top of that
I'm you know email uh you know checking
stats stocks uh if I went to the
bathroom without my phone I feel like I
feel I feel like I was gonna freak out
constantly listening to audiobooks
constantly listening to podcasts no
silence so I just like hit this weird
Breaking Point August 1st where I woke
up
and I was like I'm not stoked to get her
to bed I'm not depressed objectively
everything is fine I'm like I'm just
like I have like anhedania like I'm just
not excited about anything so I just
said it I'm just gonna what what
what's that word you just said that was
a good one yeah it means like an
inability to feel pleasure right like
nothing nothing would get me pumped
nothing would give me a hit like you
know you know when you like you're
always you go on Netflix you're like
scrolling endlessly for the perfect
thing you just can't find it that's how
my life felt and so I basically you know
it's the middle August I live in British
Columbia it's super beautiful and so I
just said to my wife you know what I'm
out for the next month let's just go off
to our cabin we'll you know we'll go on
some trips and I'm just gonna totally
check out and I said a couple rules for
myself I was like no phone no email no
computer no podcasts uh no phone calls
no social media no news I couldn't even
read non-fiction business books right so
it's pretty extreme
and I put on my Apple watch which has
you know cellular so I was like okay if
there's an emergency I can get a phone
call and I put my phone in a drawer and
I just disappeared I went up to my cabin
and hung out with my kids and honestly
for the first like three or four days it
felt like there was like a bug in my
brain like I was just like so like like
something I I itch I couldn't scratch
like just so irritable as being a huge
uh I was like slapping my pocket
every five seconds to check stuff I'd be
sitting on the beach with my kids and
I'd constantly be like oh I need to text
this to a friend I gotta I gotta take a
photo of this right so it's really weird
horrible withdrawal but then after like
three or four days I was like holy crap
like this is really interesting I
started reading fiction books and just
sitting for hours uh you know enjoying a
sunset taking a silent Drive doing all
this stuff
and I think it's kind of like if you eat
junk food all the time like you're
drinking Coke and having burgers and
stuff all the time and then you eat
broccoli it doesn't taste that good your
brain is primed for like these extreme
flavors and then if you switch to
broccoli you know you don't eat those
things for a month then you eat broccoli
broccoli is like orgasmic it's amazing
and so anyway I did this for four weeks
and I was feeling really good and I came
back to life like I kind of reintroduced
myself into society and started going
out and working and stuff and it was
really bizarre like I you know would
listen to a song that was playing in a
cafe and it'd be like the greatest song
I've ever heard I'd read some random
article and it would be like fascinating
and I'd just be completely uh like just
you know engage with it
um and then problems I had to solve that
would have pissed me off like seemed
like no problem when I was excited to
solve them and I was kind of going like
man why why did that work like what was
it about that and at the same time like
around then I started listening to
podcasts again and I listened to this
podcast by Andrew huberman huberman lab
which I'm sure you guys have listened to
he's amazing yeah he's uh he's coming on
the podcast oh amazing that's that's
awesome so he did this deep dive on
addiction and he did it with this woman
Anna Lemke who's a Stanford addiction
doctor and I was like oh this will be
interesting it'll be about like heroin
addiction or something and how they
treat alcoholism so I'll start listening
to it those other people who have those
other bad problems
it's fun it's fun to read about them
totally I was like I was like oh this
will be you know maybe philanthropic you
know I can help fund the heroin
Addiction Center in Victoria or
something so anyway and as I listen I
just go like oh my God like you know
this is not this is universal like
basically the chemical of dopamine the
neurotransmitter is the thing that makes
you feel craving and pleasure when you
do things and it motivates you to do
things and I realized you know basically
like she said you know something along
the lines of if you eat chocolate cake
once a month it tastes amazing
and you don't really crave it that much
you don't really think about it that
much it's very pleasurable if you eat it
once a week you know it's still
enjoyable but it sounds good and you
start having cravings you start wanting
chocolate cake if you eat it every day
your brain literally craves it and
you're in pain until you eat it and when
you eat it it's not even that enjoyable
it just makes the pain go away for a
little bit and she Compares that to like
heroin addiction or anything and so you
know here we all are we're stimulating
ourselves with social media 24 7. we're
constantly taking these hits and the
hits become less and less enjoyable and
she talked about you know she's at
Stanford so she's treating students and
she talks about these kids that would
come in and they're addicted to social
media and video games and they have no
motivation and so she said look I
basically recommend a dopamine fast for
four weeks they can't do any of that
stuff they gotta go walk in silence
Drive in silence have Quiet Moments not
avoid those things and I realized that
you know I'd basically done that uh for
myself and that's why I felt better and
I you know I was an addict it's crazy
[Music]
laughs